大家好。现在我来给大家介绍一下怎样使用实时同步数据。
在之前的介绍中,我们已经设置好了店群。
在这个店群里有一个组电和一个分电。
下面我们要来为这个店群这两个店铺进行实时同步的设置。
点击这里,点击这个菜单,实时同步数据,然后进到这个页面。
在这个页面的话,大家可以看到有两个标签。
一个是管理关联的规则,另外一个是查看同步的记录。
在这个管理关联的规则里面,这里应该是会显示所有实时同步的这些关联,一对一的关联。
那么现在初识化的时候是没有的,这个时候我们需要添加管理。
但是在这个之前的话,我们先来看一下这个菜单,先介绍一下这里。
这里的话是显示的是哪个是分店。
就是说我现在的话是要把设计从左边的店铺一同步给右边的店铺二。
这是设计的同步的方向。
如果您这里有多个分店的话,比如说有测试店铺三、四、五,您可以一次选择每一个进行单独的设置。
好了,那么现在我们来添加一下关联点击这个按钮。
坦出框这里可以看到左边是主店,右边是分店,那么我们可以点一下查询。
右边也可以点查询。
可以看到查出来两个店铺的商品。
那么我们做实时同步的话是要用那个一样的那个商品进行实时同步的。
这里有两种方法可以设置,一种的话是点这个自动关联商品。
在这里的话您可以勾选一下您要实时同步那些数据,比如说库村,编码,价格,商家价等等。
选好之后直接点确定,那系统的话会在后台自动为您匹配这些商品。
那它匹配的原则的话就是用商品编码唯一的编码,或者说是商品的标题呀,这些属性。
但如果您的编码又没有,标题又不一样,编码也不一样,那这个可能匹配下来就匹配不上。
那这个时候需要您手动去关联一下,比如说我们先演示一下怎么来手动关联。
大家明显看出来这两个商品是同样的一个商品。
我们左右两边一勾,选中这个商品,然后点手动关联商品这个按钮点一下。
好了,在这个弹出框里我们勾选上要同步的数据,比如说库存,还有同步什么?
同步编码,上下架。
好了,这是我们要同步的数据先勾选上。
然后在下面这个区域可以看到左边的话是组电的,右边这边是分电的。
那么中间是空白的,空白的就是说需要我们自己手动去对应一下。
手动去对应一下,你可以去做拖载。
比如说我们要跟把右边的拖过来,要跟组电的哪一个对应。
这是一种方法,还有一种方法,你可以在这个地方填上它的数字。
比如说我们取个例子,比如说这个端生群R跟这个6是对应的。
那么在这个上面就要填个6。
好了,那么手标移出去,它就自动的跟这个6这里就对应好了。
这也是一种方法。
还有一种方法,就是您点这个里边,自动匹配。自动匹配的话,它会根据您这个SKU的SKU的编码,SKU的名字会做一些智能的匹配。
大部分情况下,如果他们的编码是一致的,那它是匹配得上的。你看这张就说更方便一点。
如果这个编码SKU的编码名字又都不一样,那可能就匹配不上。
譬如上的话,就需要您去用鼠标去拖拽,这样来对应,或者在这个小方框里填数字,这样来对应。
现在的话,这个SKU都已经对应上了,你看这一条条,它就变整起来。
然后的话,再点一个确定,这个商品就算对应好了。
好了,下面我们来把这些框框先关掉。
点一下查询,看一下刚刚设置好的对应。
可以看到这个对应已经在这里了,这个关联好的。
您可以随时查看,可以查看这个SKU的对应关系,包括它这个匹配的那些数据。
这些都可以随时查看。
但是查看这边之后,查看之后您是可以修改的,比如这个不想对应的话,把它拿走。
这也是可以随时修改的。
拓走之后,点一下确定就可以随时修改。
这里可以另一面可以看到我这个对应,我同步了那些数据。
这里显示了库存编码和商家家同步了这些数据。
然后这一项是它当前的库存编码。
这里还有一个情状态。
如果说您在某一时刻,您这个对应的关联,不想让它去实时同步这三个数据了。
但是您就想保存这个关联关系。
您说将来可能会再启用。
那么您可以先把这个关掉。
暂时的话把它禁用。
那这时候它就不会再实时同步了。
或者比如说你啥时候您又想需要把它给打开。
你得把它启用一下就可以了。
当然了,这边还有一些批量的一些按钮来帮助您快速批量设置。
比如说您要删除您可以批量的选择。
然后这边点删除。
或者说您要修改。
比如说我这边假设我这里设置了有很多的这个对应。
我要把他们这个对应从这三个批量全部换成只有一个库存。
那我这里就可以全部勾选。
然后这里。
把它想要库存点确定。
这时候就行了。
它就自动的批量全部改成库存了。
好了那这边设置好了之后的话。
系统就会自动的把左边这个商品的它的这个库存变动啊。
编码变动还有上下下的变动。
就会实时的给同步给右边这个商品。
这叫这个是单方向同步。
如果您那个需要有这个在右边这个店铺这个商品有变化的时候。
数据变化的时候也需要先向左边再更新到左边的店铺的话。
那您可以就把这儿改一下可以改成双向的。
这个点了之后您可以改一下改成一个互相同步。
这就是两边有变动的话它都会同步给另外一边。
这样这样就说一般情况下。
一般都是用组电为基准。
组电就把它改成双向同步就可以了。
那这边这个就介绍完了。
然后我们可以看一下。
查看同步记录。
在这个地方的话,
如果您那边关联那边都设置了很多,
那么经过一段时间之后就会有很多的同步记录。
这些同步记录就会显示出来。
在这里的话您可以根据状态,
或者根据某个商品ID,
甚至根据这个备注去查询,
可以看到这个同步的一些情况。
嗯,好了,这里的话就是给大家介绍了一下,
怎样在这里设置这个实时同步,
并去查看实时同步的记录。
好了,谢谢大家。